porque que verifica a sua linha do tempo
numa rede social é mais interessante do
que fez participar da aula que você
deveria está interagindo por que que eu
entro nos laboratórios nas universidades
encontro pesquisadores tristes pesarosos
sem aquele brilho no olho para conduzir
as pesquisas que são os seus projetos de
vida talvez porque as universidades do
país que tem o segundo maior programa de
acesso ao ensino superior o enem
o segundo maior programa do mundo
acessem ensino superior o enem hoje
apresenta maior taxa de abandono que nos
últimos dez anos
é a universidade está chata mas conta
que foi isso aconteceu eu trago eu trago
para vocês uma metáfora que talvez ajude
a gente a visualizar por que isso
acontece
bem porque a gente come eu com porque eu
gosto de comer e por que comer bolo de
cenoura lembrar casa da minha avó porque
preparar o jantar em casa significa que
eu vou estar com pessoas queridas
reunidas o alimento me deixa feliz e ele
ele tem esse papel de trazer lembrança
prazer socialização para muitas pessoas
e esse papel psicossocial do alimento é
muito mais determinante importante nas
escolhas alimentares das pessoas do que
simplesmente o ato de que eu como pra
dar energia o meu corpo nutre das minhas
células
eu escolho os alimentos porque eles têm
história porque eles fazem sentido para
mim e eu acredito que da mesma forma
acontece o processo de ensino
aprendizagem vão estar aberto a ele
ele tem de ressoar com o meu propósito
nisso a universidade tem pecado muito
assim durante a graduação eu tive
oportunidade de ficar imersa numa das
cidades de menor idh do brasil eu
participei do projeto rondon e durante o
planejamento das atividades eu eu
pesquisei sobre a região eu criei um
tanto de atividades que eu julgava serem
importantes para aquela comunidade que
eles deviam saber
e aí quando chegou lá nas atividades de
campo eu me deparei com o inesperado
as respostas e as práticas que eu tinha
levado não dialogavam com aquela
população ou seja as perguntas deles
eram diferentes das respostas que eu
tinha levado
e aí eu me vi vulnerável e foi
desesperador porque é a primeira vez que
eu me vi como profissional de graduação
como futura nutricionista
eu me vi perdida eu passei a repensar o
meu papel como estudantes de graduação
com pesquisadora e com um ser social e
isso foi muito importante pra hoje eu
descobri que uma das minhas maiores
paixões é trabalhar com o
desenvolvimento de comunidades e
alimentação é trabalhar com pessoas e a
partir disso é nasceu com essas
inquietações com essa com essa vontade
de fazer dialogar com as perguntas das
universidades com as perguntas do mundo
real que eu participei eu integro hoje o
projeto álbuns ou mesmo que é um projeto
que a gente busca somar tudo tudo
conhecimento técnico científico com o
saber popular fazendo isso de uma forma
plena e humano assim e como o projeto
algas nasceu e nós não tem mar mas a
gente trabalha com alga marinha
o ministério da aquicultura e pesca
extinto ministério da cultura e pesca
junto com a falta
trouxe o desafio de um projeto grande
que é o desenvolvimento de comunidades
costeiras e apresentou desafio uma
professora lá de natal que resolveu vim
pra terras de minas e aí um desafio de
desenvolver uma linha de produtos à base
de algas marinhas para ampliar a
utilização de uma alga que tinha o seu
cultivo é já bem consolidado assim
agregar valor a uma matéria prima e aí
eu curiosa alta marinha mas aumentá-la
no mar e aqui não tem mar
topei esse desafio durante dois anos da
pesquisa eu fiquei estudando o que só
obtinha aspectos nutricionais enquanto
estava só no laboratório falava assim
olha que legal
essa alga e tem umas coisas legais em
fibra enfim
mas aí no segundo ano do projeto eu
conheci
pra quem que aquelas aulas tinham
sentido eu tive a oportunidade de
conhecer as três comunidades nordeste
que cultivavam aquela alga e que em uma
escala muito pequenininha consumiam ela
eu falava assim poxa ao de thala mas há
uma usada como alimento e aí eu vi que
só consumir aquelas algas as
maricultores que conheciam todo o
processo de cultivo ea história que
tinha pra trás delas
aquelas mulheres em que as algas não
revela mas não comiam as drogas porque
elas tinham fibras e fazer um bem para a
saúde porque era um instrumento de
trabalho delas elas entendiam a história
que tinha por trás daquilo tudo
e aí eu fui sensibilizado a cimpor
nossa que legal um objeto de que antes
era só um objeto de pesquisa ele faz
sentido ele carrega uma história com
alguém e junto com a ação dessas
maricultoras a gente criou nossos quinho
que é alga marinha contando a sua
história
e esses quinho foi longe e cicinho foi
nas praças
elas apenas igrejas a nordeste mostrando
um alimento com potencial e com uma
abundância tão grande para eles e que
era parte da cultura deles e com isso a
gente conseguiu gerar um reconhecimento
e eles foram protagonistas dessa
história de transformação e eu me vi com
uma universitária apenas sendo com uma
catalizador de uma de uma riqueza que
era dele só precisava de um estímulo
para florescer ver algo que você
trabalha fazendo sentido pra alguém é
transformadora assim e aí eu sempre me
preocupei assim que a universidade ela
me proporcionou isso
e quantas pessoas somente passam pela
universidade hoje por ironia do destino
ou não eu sou professor universitário e
aí
além do desafio de fazer esse despertar
e sensibilizar dos alunos
eu carrego pra mim como a gente pode
desafiá lo a desenvolver essa
curiosidade genuína
uma curiosidade que ela tem o poder de
fazer uma inventariação e reinventar e
recriar esse é um sujeito ativo do seu
processo de transformação dos
professores
eu acredito que tem esse papel de não de
passar conhecimento conhecimento está aí
mas de facilitar esse encontro de cada
um com nós mesmos e até os próprios
docentes de possibilitar um ambiente em
que essa troca de saberes ela dialoga de
uma forma muito fluida e que tudo isso
acontece
assim hoje nós somos sete milhões e meio
de estudantes nas universidades
brasileiras incluindo mestrandos e
doutorandos
nós representamos 25 nosso estamos entre
os 25 países que mais publicam artigos
científicos no mundo
representa uma elite de 5% de todos os
brasileiros que têm acesso ao ensino
superior ea minha pergunta é o que a
gente está criando o que a gente está
fazendo de útil para os outros 95%
a revista leite e publicou que essa lo
colocação do brasil de 23º lugar no
último mundial de uma das que mais
publicam artigos não se traduz nas
qualidades 10 publicação e nem na
utilização e na eficiência de utilização
desses recursos aplicados à pesquisa
ou seja o brasil ele é o único país da
américa latina que investe mais de 1 por
cento do seu produto interno bruto em
pesquisa em pesquisa e desenvolvimento
e aí quando a gente avalia é o
rendimento disso o número de publicações
ela se equiparam ao chile que investe
apenas 0,4 por cento
e aí eu pergunto é e eu pergunto esse
cenário ele não reflete um pouco como as
nossas pesquisas estão sendo conduzidas
nas universidades
o quão aquilo tem feito sentido ficar a
saber falar dos problemas das
universidades é muito fácil e já tem
várias teorias levantando esses
problemas mas a grande questão e o
desafio mesmo continua como transformá
lá e isso só é feito através de uma
mudança de atitude como essa mudança de
atitude pode se dar através da gente tem
o papel ea possibilidade de fazer
funcionar a multidisciplinaridade que é
um ambiente mais plural que uma
universidade em que eu tenho pessoas de
todos os tipos de todas as culturas
reunidas
será que isso não tá será que estamos
xando de dialogar entre esses atores ou
seja as nossas pesquisas elas são tão
compartimentalizada dados segmentados
será que não podemos nos envolver todos
no mesmo universo né e muito além muito
além disso eu pergunto professores e
estudantes
vamos fazer funcionar o que a gente
tanto fala de horizontalidade como eu
acredito que há um caminho
será que aquelas há provas extensa
daqueles trabalhos altamente teórico
eles não podem ser substituído por
desafios reais com problemas reais de
uma comunidade que tá ali depois das 44
será que ao invés de os trabalhos finais
não podem acontecer de uma forma multi
cêntrica em que ao invés de um grande
relatório eu entregue os projetos que
foram desenvolvidos a interação que teve
com a comunidade os negócios criados
algo prático algo que meu me mostre e
propoe e acrescente o aluno ele vê o
resultado daquilo que ele pensou
vamos aprendendo na prática eu acredito
que esse seja seja um dos caminhos para
trilhar mas não só o único e aí com
integrando todo esse ecossistema
a gente tem que os órgãos de fomento
será que eles não podem pensar em
instrumentos de avaliação mais humanos e
menos quantitativos do número de uma
produção científica avaliá avaliar o
desempenho do docente
a entrega numa sala de aula avaliar do
mesmo modo com o mesmo valor que as
pesquisas científicas
a integração na extensão o ensino
fazendo tudo funcionar em um mesmo
patamar e dando igual importância porque
consolida uma frase hoje cobrar
mas há a publicação a produção ali e na
paixão de criar esse gente não queria
algo novo como que a gente vai mudar a
gente precisa pensar nisso
e aí já encerrando
eu queria questionar pra vocês
vamos alunos substituir aquelas
perguntas vai cair na prova foi uma
possui contas mais inteligentes que
ajudam resolver problemas do mundo e
também buscar soluções inovadoras
soluções inovadoras para a resolução
daqueles problemas porque a partir disso
a gente gera um movimento
a gente faz acontecer a gente cria uma
demanda pra um âmbito maior desse
ecossistema gerar toda a vontade
política a alocação de recursos por uma
coisa que funciona e que não fica só nos
papéis que transforma nossa vida
então o desafiar a si
eu acredito que não honra a universidade
é formada por nós ea gente tem esse
papel e essa sonho grande de fazer
acontecer
eu acredito muito que isso é possível eu
sei que é possível e aqui a gente tá pra
fazer isso acontecer
quebrar esses muros transpor e fazer
algo transcendente que vai impactar uma
geração futura com as nossas ações hoje
mas que só para a gente ter começado já
vai fazer uma diferença danada
então vamos lá vamos colocar professores
alunos reitores
tudo junto conversando dialogando e
fazendo realmente acontecer
eu acredito que é possível jogar esse
mundo fora e fazer algo maior
em quê
na frente a gente vai se preocupar muito
mais com o propósito porque a partir
desse movimento a gente gera
profissionais muito mais engajados e vão
te vão compor a sociedade em que a gente
acredita a sociedade em que o salário no
final do mês não vai ser tão importante
do que o propósito da minha atuação como
profissional e esse embasamento esse
berço de de sonhos e possibilidades
ele pode acontecer dentro das
universidades
e aí a gente feito além de idéias de
sentimentos e ressentimentos que as
universidades trazem hoje a gente pode
transpor a gente pode transformar a
gente faz sonhar grande através das
práticas através de estarmos abertos e
fazei acontecendo a mudança
eu acredito muito obrigada foi mão